vos grands-parents, ils ont créé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire, ils étaient assez intrépides
pour croire que le monde est bien
plus vaste que ce que nous pourrions imaginer. Les
monstres monarques sont une
réalité incontournable que nous devons apprendre
pour
survivre, vous saviez que ces choses existaient,
c'est votre
héritage, le monde est  en feu, il s'est
passé quelque chose que Nar ne voulait pas que
nous sachions,
c'est une carte ouais mais qu'est-ce que c'est une
carte
de nous pouvons faire ça ensemble nous pouvons
le
comprendre Je ne prends plus d'ordres de Monarch le
temps de Cowboy jusqu'à ce que
nous le soyons  en regardant une vague d'
événements Titan menaçant la vie de 7
milliards de personnes et si les trois pouvaient
sauver les sept
milliards